where i want to start with glenn junkin
who joins us now as i mentioned we
invited terry mcauliffe as well and we
are here if he wants to um hop on and
talk to us as well mr juncken good to
see you today you heard rich edson's
report he he talks about the early vote
which went all the way back to september
16th people started voting and about a
fifth of the virginia electorate already
voted before you started to take off in
the polls are you concerned that that
could
sort of throw things in terry
mcauliffe's direction tomorrow night
no i i felt like the early voting was
very much representative of of our
strength in fact turnout for my opponent
was really light and soft and we had
strong turnout and so we expect to do
very well with the early voting and the
momentum that we're seeing on the
campaign trail is just it's just huge i
got to be honest everywhere we go the
crowds are giant and we have had this
10-day bus tour we've been all over the
commonwealth and we've had standing room
only people falling out the doors and
and it's so exciting to watch virginians
come together because it's no longer
republicans against democrats this is
virginians coming together for a
platform that they can believe in with
low taxes and safe schools and safe
neighborhoods and education that works
for our children let me ask you about
the way of job market that's really
growing you know we've seen those crowds
um it's pretty evident on the video when
we see those crowds but but i think it's
like 51 of the early vote is democrat so
why do you say that you feel like um you
know you you would have done well in
that early portion of the vote
well historically early voting has been
you know 75 to 80 percent democrat and
so for us to be so strong in the early
voting just reflects the fact that
there's not any enthusiasm on my
opponent's side and we've had a lot of
enthusiasm and then we expect to do
really well tomorrow uh you know
virginians are coming together and this
is why we see so much momentum going
into tomorrow but also the early voting
is going to be i think surprisingly good
for us we'll see it's fascinating to
watch here's what terry mcauliffe said
in the closing hours here watch this
we don't want a trump wannabe someone
who's been endorsed by donald trump 10
times tonight closing his campaign is
donald trump i mean we don't need the
hatred the division
tell a rally uh by the former president
are you as he says closing your campaign
with president trump
well we've had help from everybody and i
there is a tele a teleconference tonight
that that president trump is hosting and
we're going to be off holding a rally in
loudoun county we've been getting help
from everybody we had governors from all
over the united states uh hosting
telecalls yesterday to get the vote out
from idaho and arizona and south
carolina and iowa it was fabulous to see
the whole republican party come together
and oh by the way to see independence
we're winning we're winning independent
vote by double digits we've got
democrats walking across the aisle this
is what unity looks like and this is why
we're going to win on tuesday but we got
to get the vote out polls don't win
elections votes do and so we're
encouraging everybody to get out and
vote and i know you've been doing that
in the southwest part of the state today
it's been fun to watch this this race
and we look forward to covering it
tomorrow glenn young thank you very much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else